[Music]
welcome to for coming to our sessions on
K native eventing March Marnie I'm one
of the technical program enters our
serger looking after service and I'm
bill I guess I work on the K Native I've
been working on it from the beginning
and most recently I've been working on
the eventing side of the K native so
that's what we're talking about today
first of all thank you for coming I know
this is the last day of the conference
and even getting this audience here is
great and it also is going to be a 300
level session so we're gonna go little
deeper in technology we're gonna do all
kinds of demos well to at least two
demos maybe three we're gonna do there's
gonna be cube CTL commands that are
gonna be a mole so definitely definitely
lots of fun the other thing I want to
kind of quickly just give heads up is
we've recently this week we dropped a
new version of K native so everything
we're going to be showing today is based
on that version of K native that just
landed this week there is a blog post
that we published this earlier this
morning that overviews all the new
features in zero 5 of k native don't
read right now but later later on by the
way the dory is also open for this
session so Villa and I are here
obviously so we're not gonna be able to
open our real time but as soon as this
is over we'll jump in and provide
answers and we'll hopefully have some
time also to take real time on certain
questions
all right so very quickly I know how
many of you worked on or touch cañedo
for use k native worked on Candida in
any kind of interaction with Canada all
right so we have we have some people but
not many so why don't we take a quick
kind of level 100 overview of k native
for about three to five minutes and then
we can go deeper in so once we level
said first of all k native is a set of
open source building blocks that are
there specifically kind of oriented for
building service on top of kubernetes
what that means is that last July at
this very conference we have launched a
native as an open source project and we
had at that time four other partners who
worked with us on that we were very much
focusing on those building block
concepts knowing that people can pick
and choose those components that
needed but we also saw a lot of
commonality that people were working on
in the community and you know while
there were very interesting and complex
they were also not very differentiating
so people people were often not being
able to get us user-friendly experience
using building service and kubernetes as
they normally would so we launched this
is on github under Apache 2 license and
right from the start we focus
specifically on three areas initially
but the space is growing we focus on
building which how do you get to an
image that you can actually use some
cougar on kubernetes that would be
friendly for service type of workloads
we focus on eventing which we're going
to be talking about today and we focus
on serving which is clearly how you're
going to be accessing this the server
stack at the time so very much still
focusing on this modern type of
workloads what that means is that you
know if you have like a stateful
application this might not be a good fit
for 4k native but if you're working in a
kind of modern stock 12 factor
applications microservices this is very
much kind of geared towards delivering
the best experience of developing on top
of communities for you it also includes
10 plus years of building service stock
in Coober in at Google so all the
learnings from those products are kind
of applied in here as both from Google
as well as number of partners in a
community so that's that's pretty
exciting so very quickly I'm a lot of
overview each one of those components so
we had a serving built and events for
serving and build very quickly so
there's a couple benefits that
developers get from from Canada today
first of all the one that we always
stress is this automatic auto scaling
basically you deploy their workload and
we take care of this underlining auto
scaling based on requests so or usage
from of that workload not on something
like CPU which might be more traditional
way of auto scaling for kubernetes and
what that means is that we can auto
scale through activation when the
request is being made and then we also
can scale it down to zero when
when that workload is not being used
which is very helpful for obvious
utilization reasons so if you have a
kubernetes cluster that cluster can be
used to provide other services or
resources that can be managed through
other workloads they are a very
interesting part for in serving is that
we kind of from the day one focused on
looking at deployments as a combination
of configuration and the actual code so
it goes in unit with fries that we
identify it we manage it for you and
what that means that at any given time
you can roll back you can deploy a new
version and roll back to the last
previous known state knowing that it
will go with the configuration that was
true at that time the if you if you've
been building applications the the very
common pattern that we see over and over
is you come to a conference like this
you've seen some new language a new
framework new service you get excited
you build that service it goes live you
startling get users yeah it's exciting
and now you find out that there is a bug
well I would you right perfect code so
you would not be the case for your code
obviously but and now you need to update
that application but you have users who
constantly use it so one of the things
that a native enables you to do is
provide a way to manage that that and
provides patterns like blue green which
allows you to shadow a new version
behind and switch the traffic to new one
and also use some kind of experiment
framework that will allow you to
incrementally switch the traffic to new
version switch the traffic to a version
that's not exposed to the users and in
with a name route access it or any
combination between so a lot of good
learnings there the access control is
the last one I list there but this year
just highlight so obviously we can go
deeper on that and in a given time
there's a lot of documentation so this
deals with the fact that you might have
if you're building micro services sooner
or later you end up with 10 20 and if
you're doing it for a while it's going
to be hundreds of micro services and
only one or two of those need to be
externally accessible with the request
access path control that's integrated
based on keen on east yo Inc a native
you can manage that by not exposing
routes to services that don't have to be
externally accessible so it's very
helpful
on a build side right from the day one
we were focused on delivering
reproducible builds that's comes very
critical if you want to be able to
assure that the same version of the same
version of code built multiple times can
result in the exact same image and it
also enables us to start kind of
exposing through sort through build
templates ways for people to optimize
different frameworks and different
languages for build pipelines that allow
developers to go directly from source
all the way to a URL so yes there is an
image in between there but the developer
doesn't have to see it eliminates a lot
of pain around cross compiling like
number of flags and all I can go is not
too complicated but if you go to Java
you want to compile from Java on a Mac
to Java on Linux in my you might have
some different challenges there and also
removes the need for docker in terrible
entirely on your workstation because
it's built on the service you send you
send your build job it compiles it
builds that image for you and handles
the entire thing and because it's a
cloud I've seen it runs on top of
kubernetes you have access to all the
caching and all the elasticity of that
framework of the service and you can
leverage big VMs for the build process
and you can decommission them afterwards
and use use other nodes that maybe are
more optimized for bursty type of
workloads so that's that's excellent
very quickly this is just high-level
over here because for the rest of the
session we're going to go deep into the
eventing so eventing more than anything
is all about orchestrating the the
actual events on your cluster both for
the event sources that happen externally
to the cluster as well if they have an
ANA cluster itself one of the things
that we also focus from the day one is
making sure that that experience for the
developer is very declarative so you
don't go in run some commands that then
suddenly you have to rerun if the notes
change but you tell us the state that we
want that you want and using the same
principle that's applicable to the
entire kubernetes stack you get that sir
you get that event registered and bound
for the for you higher-level objects
made it much easier to reason about so
you can kind of always come back and
invest interrogate your configuration
understand what exactly has happened
even though you might have you know set
it up two weeks three weeks
and and because it's built on top of
those kinetic events are built on top of
serving you you continue getting access
to that dynamic scalability so we allows
you to build this very simple trigger
demonstration we're going to show in a
minute here when you wire a some kind of
event to a directly to a service and
just fire it automatically all the way
to very complex complex pipeline and I
every day I'm amazed by you know what
people are building channels triggers
filters fan outs all kinds of stuff all
of that is based on open standard for
event transport so cloud events is what
we utilize inside of ke native and on
the end of this under the on the end of
the day sorry is extendable so what that
means is that yes we have out say about
20 different sources they're already
published on the que native website that
are built by the community you can
consume those you don't have to build
this but you know what if we're one of
this one of those that you need is not
there you can always come back and and
and build a new one and Vila is going to
show you later how relatively easy that
can be for different kind of use cases
so without further ado let's talk about
eventing thanks mark all right so yes so
we are really excited to go ahead and be
here and talk about the new inventing
model we have spent several months in
looking at the use cases how people use
the objects that we put together in the
I don't know point 2.3 release and
getting a lot of feedback from the users
and those and and hearing it loud and
clear that yeah yep pretty tricky to put
together when we started the service
that it was a little bit easier because
kubernetes had a lot of primitives that
we could use and they lend themselves
quite well for building the serving
stack for the inventing not so much so
we have to do a lot of work on there
making sure that those primitives are
bright so that we can then build
something really neat on top of that so
we are going to talk about the two new
objects that we introduced the the if
you have used the eventing before there
are other things in there but these are
the new ones that we talked about
because we think they make the most
sense as a user
go ahead and reason about this A to B
system and to make it useful
so really the developer cares about one
thing and one thing only which is to go
and say I want to go and take events
like this and I want to send them over
here
if you think about it like that that
makes sense to me so you don't really
care about where those events came from
right that should be a detail that you
should not worry about it like I just
want to go ahead and know when an object
is uploaded to my storage for example
and when that happens to the thumbnail
er the classic example but you do
however care about how these events show
up in your function and that's mark
mentioned we are using cloud events so
it's a CNC F spec that a lot of
companies are working on including
Google so we are standing on the
shoulders of the great work that other
people have been doing so we want to go
and emphasize the fact that you as the
function developer can go ahead and have
a standard way of consuming these events
so you go and get the cloud events and
by using these two new models that the
broker and trigger the a brilliant
unified the consumption which is where
you say hey I would like to go and
receive these events and put them over
here a function or whatever and then it
also unifies the event production side
of things and we'll talk a little bit
more about that one but there's really
nice there's a really nice model so that
you can think about and reason about the
system at the high level so let's look
at these two objects a little bit more
in detail so developers are proper
cannot use this resource the most which
is really allowing them to go ahead and
say hey when this event type happens
please call this function over here
today so some examples of this won't be
like hey when when when a PR is put into
a github then do some things with that
right and we actually use this we use
this in the K native repo we have many
of these little robots that do things
like fix pay
spelling mistakes or go ahead and make
sure the llamo looks right and thinking
things like that so so so we are using
this in the K native and it's it's it's
really really neat so that's a good
example for that or you might want to
say hey you know when when when objects
are load loaded into
GCSE I'm gonna go and receive those but
only certain kinds so that's that the
the concept of the filtering there so
the other nice thing is they're in this
model the trigger or your function code
can actually go ahead and just return a
new event type so if you for example
want to go ahead and say like hey I want
to take some kind of an event but it
might contain some sensing information
that I don't want everybody else to see
you can go ahead and either create a new
event or even type and then even go and
feed it back in the system so the so it
makes the function writers job much much
easier on that sense so in this
particular one for example you're saying
hey I'm gonna convert events from combat
example to at some event and we are
sending it to a subscriber and if you're
familiar with que kubernetes or que
native that is basically an object graph
in this case it is using a serving
service start serving the other new
event is the event poker and this is
really I personally think of it as the
event delivery system or the mesh so
when you come into a namespace of your
choosing and you decide that you want to
sprinkle some que native eventing on it
you can just go ahead and apply a label
on that namespace and the que native
will install a broker for you in that
namespace and as a side effect of that
you will now get a discoverable endpoint
slash predictable endpoint so that you
can go ahead and now target that event
mesh from any other namespace or from
the same namespace as well so you can
also install multiple upon multiple of
these as well into your namespace or you
know multiple namespaces and you might
say well why would I want to do that and
really there's there's a couple of
different reasons but one of the things
that happens underneath the scenes for
the broker is it has to manage some
messaging layers so these are the
channels if you've been using the pick a
native venting in the past and you might
want to call and choose a couple of
different broker models so and one of
them in white gonna say I don't want to
lose any of these events so I'm willing
to go and pay the cost of persisting
them into into a persistent messaging
and the other one is where you might
just be doing some you don't care
and you might choose to go and do things
like in-memory implementation where if
an event gets lost fine we'll run again
or what not so you have some options
there but you get it for free if you
just label the namespace and you also
you can also go and use the broker
object as for controlling access and
ingress policy into that broker so you
can say for example I don't want any
events that I have not pre authorized to
enter this broker and that that that's
one example of that the other one is
where you're doing some cheap and
cheerful testing and you just want to do
stuff produce events willy nilly and
everything else so you know good luck
with that the last one that didn't
unfortunately make it to point five but
I just wanted to point out here is that
this is this is the registry that we are
working refining as a community right
now making sure it's nice nice and
usable and really it's meant to solve
the use case of how do you discover the
event type so once you're in your broker
namespace or in your namespace you want
to be able to have an easy way to
discover what event types there are what
do they look like and so forth so this
is this is something that the registry
is going to solve and we are working
very hard to get it into the next
release so this is this is what what it
really looks like or at least how I see
the world so if you think about from the
left-hand side there we have two two
event sources that are prosing events
and they both you know so there's the
red and then there's the blue source and
they are both pushing those events into
the broker where the broker is happily
receiving them and then a developer
comes in on the right hand side there's
and and defines one of those triggers
where they come in and saying like hey I
am actually interested in the red events
so you create a trigger where you
specify that the filtering is red and
now your service gets called only for
the red events and on the on the bottom
side you can profit guess that then that
one gets only the blue events right the
in the both cases of the service I just
highlighted the fact that it's it's
callable because it's using something
that in the que natively make extensive
use of to make it easy
extend implacable it's a duck typing
concept that Matt Moore and I have been
working on for a while so so the nice
thing is that you can put different
kinds of things one of those is a que
native service from the serving stack
but you can use you can you can put
these things into other places well so
let's go ahead and see what this looks
like in action mark has cooked up
something neat yeah so before we go
there a little setup here now this chart
looks very this diagram looks very
complex and we will kind of break it
down I kind of put a little line around
this where we're going to be focusing
today what we're gonna do is we're gonna
create a very simplistic trigger that
will fire on a pops up event pops up is
a very simple globally distributed event
messaging system that's easy to consume
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a simple trigger that will
fire whenever a new event arrives but I
wasn't going to create new events myself
so what we're gonna do is actually gonna
leverage one of the events that already
generated by cloudbuilt if you attended
some of the cloud run demos I've used
that demonstration there so we'll fire
simple build and or whatever that build
publishes a new status of a build will
attach to it and fire an event now
events are great on but not really
meaningful until you can see them so
what are we going to do in this case
we're going to send this to to slack in
order to be able to display the actual
content of that so can we switch to the
demo machine well make sure if slack is
running - all right so first thing what
are we gonna do is can you see this yeah
it's pretty good so what we're gonna do
is we're going to look at the the
trigger object in here so if you've
worked with kubernetes before you you
should be very familiar with the fact
that there is some namespace for the API
and the version in this case we've
created a new object called trigger that
trigger allows us to name it and you
know for demo purposes I named it pretty
long but you can name it whatever you
want there's we really going with a lot
of defaults in here so we're using the
serving name namespace to be able to
define an addressable object in this
case our addressable object is going to
be our notification service building the
ones we're gonna send those events to so
let's go and
fired this up so cube CTL apply config
again very kubernetes friendly way of
doing it there is number of CL eyes now
there are already available in a
community 4k natives so that if you come
from if you're coming from kubernetes
you're very familiar with cube CTL you
can run this anytime right or keep Carol
the pinch attends there's a bottle still
how to exactly pronounce it but if
you're familiar with that you can
continue using that but there is number
of CLI available to actually hide even
that from you and our we just deal
specifically only with the key native
objects a and chemical or KN CTL is one
of those key native project has its own
CLI building being built right now so we
welcome to trials but in this case we're
going to go straight to keep CTL we're
gonna apply this house they commonly be
enough yeah so what do we have that
message is that the the trigger was
created but let's not trust those
messages let's run get triggers and I'm
running everything in a demos namespace
just for isolation purposes but what you
will see here is that we got the let me
see if I can make this bigger there we
go you got the the name the status each
trigger has its internal URL obviously
that's not accessible externally and the
H in here so what we've done now is
we've set up the trigger that's all I
had to do in order to connect attach
myself to the source of events so let's
generate some events now very quickly
before we even go there let's take a
look at that actual service that service
is really just for demo purposes but
what it does has couple of interesting
things here first of all there's a
handler that whenever it receives those
cloud events we talked remember we
talked about the transport always is in
cloud event so you can trust that the
type you gonna be getting is going to be
try at a cloud events we're gonna get
one of those types we're gonna extract
the actual message of that and then
we're gonna send it to a sender that
among women decorates nice message and
in a very end it just sends it to slack
and hopefully if everything goes well
fingers crossed a in our demo we're
gonna be able to go in and see the
status being published so let's go to
I have a simple pipeline set up here so
again I don't have to build anything
myself we're gonna create a simple new
release I'm gonna deve some name key
native trigger demo obviously you should
be doing some better releases but since
you're watching over here I'm just gonna
say no release no it's very sad and
submit so a cloudbuilt gives us a easy
way to kind of get a get and kind of
peek at what's going on so there's one
fired already
I'm not gonna go through all these
details of what happens here cloudbuilt
gives you easy way to kind of attach
yourself to source repository and this
one is firing on it on a label sorry on
a tag you can do this on a branches and
all that but let's let's go to our slack
and see what's going on over there
hopefully this is all public so it's not
like any secrets in here key native
Channel we see our notification arrived
for a next demo 25 starting working if I
waited long enough if I went to the
status and waited for that to finish
built it would eventually send another
status change saying I was working now
I'm finished and the status finished
status was built you can actually go and
gives you a link in here this is just a
demo channel so you can clearly see that
you know the message is not formatted
exactly perfectly but once the build
finishes in here you will see one of
those sadhus sadhus this change to
success so that it can change back to
the slides please
so back to our channels here we've those
events could be anything Villa was
talking about the number like get Hobbs
and pushes and everything that the
process would be one and the same you go
and trick create a trigger you attach
the trigger to some kind of event source
and we will go into the event sources in
a minute and then you also send it what
who's the consumer of those events and
in this case was a notification service
that adheres to that to that interface
and we and we send it so pretty simple
pretty easy there's number of those
demonstration in key native samples and
you can kind of reproduce this pretty
easily on your own okay native cluster
look good catch
all right so so one of the things that
we didn't talk about yet but let's talk
about them now so we really focused on
what the what the developer experience
is there but if they can come in and
said like hey here's my trigger it was
very easy to set up you basically just
said I want those kind of events I went
then go over here right that was nice
there was no mention of how did those
events show up in the cluster okay and
it's not magic it turns out we haven't
figured that out so there is some stuff
you have to do to get those events into
your cluster and by utilizing these
event sources the user is gonna care
about a couple of different things
they are gonna care about okay how do I
actually get those events them right so
you want to be able to discover this
event sources so for example if you're
like okay I really would like to go
ahead and build my own little github
robot or whatever else so how would I do
that so you want to be able to discover
that there is a github event source out
there for you right and you also want to
be able to configure those external
event sources because you you you have
to be able to do things like for example
in the gate how do you want to be able
to say I need to go and watch the events
on this particular bucket owner or repo
project and repo and you want to be able
to specify those ones and lastly we you
want to be able to go and say but that's
great but I have my own internal system
and I'm sure nobody's gonna write an
event source for that so you always have
the option of writing yourself and and
and and be able to go ahead and and use
it internally but hopefully you can come
in and and write some other external
ones and come come play with us so Kay
native event a community has already
built many of these so there is just a
very very small sample of the ones but
you can see the rich set of event
sources that you can go and come in and
start using today but many of these are
in the repo some of them are in the
different kinds of repos because they
are maintained by different people and
so forth but on the bottom that there's
a link that contains the all the event
sources and if you write none and you
want to go ahead and come in and and
expose it the wider set of users then
you can go ahead and add
to the list and just send out a PR so
let's go ahead and see what does it look
like to go and actually go ahead and use
one of these event sources so if we
first demo we talked about events
probably wired up to come into the book
into the broker and what you needed to
do was to go and create a trigger to go
and consume those so now let's go and
complete the picture and saying like
yeah okay
now let's go to look at the magic which
is not magic but what does that look
like when I go and say please give me
events of certain type so mark alright
so again back to quick overview before
we get there I'm gonna trust you today
I'm gonna ask you to actually use your
devices to post something so we can
display any here Villa is going to hold
a finger on closing the window whenever
something doesn't work I'm sure the HR
team is going to come and send me an
email afterwards but what we're going to
do is we're going to create a very
simple we're going to configure a brand
new event source for for tweets that are
matching a specific query you can guess
is going to be I will tell you the query
in a minute so we don't have to you
don't have too much time the other thing
we're going to do is we're going to go
in and configure the same trade a
different trigger but using the same
pattern we just didn't have done this
for the build status so we're gonna
create a source I'm gonna create a
trigger then we're gonna open a cane
ativ service that's a basic UI
application that's gonna display those
tweets now you have to be authenticated
to Twitter so we know who you are but
I'm trusting a lot into this whole
process alright can you switch to the
demo so in this case back to our llamo
you're gonna be in a llamo a lot if
you're working on a key native who is
obfuscating a lot of that through a CLI
sometimes but in some company or complex
cases you still have to use the mo so in
this case we're gonna use a brand new
object type called container source with
a villa we'll talk about those that's
one of the types of sources that we can
integrate into Kay native as you can
guessed it I call this the Twitter
source here is your handle so start
typing please don't get me in trouble
the other thing we're gonna do in here
is we're gonna actually start using some
more advanced features so for example in
this case I wouldn't want to show you
one is recorded tokens for my account to
connect to Twitter right that would not
be wise so we're using kubernetes
secrets that's something you can do we
can use both currently secrets as well
as volumes if that's a more use easier
pattern to use secrets we're gonna
deploy an image that represents the
actual source that's going to be
consuming this we also going to do a
couple other things in here we're going
to create a broker and we're gonna go to
a default to a default broker in here so
let's let's switch over here and the
first thing we're gonna do is this is
source yeah let's deploy this again
let's let's get the sources come on
there it is so we see the original pops
up that I was using in a previous can
demo but here is my brand new 11 second
old event source for this so that's one
what the other thing we're saying we're
gonna be doing is we're gonna be
creating a trigger you already seen a
trigger so I'm gonna focus on couple new
bits in here
first we adding a filter saying there's
there could be n number of different
types of events and Fila talked about
those different types when he was over
viewing the trigger what are we using in
here is all I want to subscribe to is
those twit Twitter triggers a lot of t
started so what we're going to do is
we're going to define the type this is
really on OPEC string but is using a
pattern that's kind of common for for
these events calm down Twitter and we're
gonna send this to a UI event that looks
like this so hopefully when everything
goes well a very nicely formatted and
clean tweets gonna show up here in a
minute
all right let's do all we have to
install this nothing happens until you
actually do this so let's clear keep CTL
applying config and this is the trigger
and make sure we going into the same
demo all right so this is created let's
just make sure it's there I don't know I
should be trusting key native to just be
there for me it never disappoints me
all right so yeah I should close this
right now so you can build a very robust
set of features can we switch to two
slide thank you very much
TJ Troezen thank you very much what
we've done we've done the entire
pipeline by creating brand new source
Villa is going to overview how to create
the actual source itself the code but we
created we configured that source on a
cluster we then went in and create a
trigger you can have n numbers of those
triggers there Lucinda listen to that
same source and we've defined the
trigger that connects that output of
those events or the events themselves
and fires a particular event so anything
targetable will work there and Villa
will overview what that means right now
simple service was a good example of
that we were using also WebSockets in
example of here that was able to kind of
refresh the page without me doing that
that's a new a couple new features
couple new transport supports that we've
added including G RPC HTTP to WebSockets
am I missing anything no all right so
simple demo easy to follow you can
easily reproduce that one as well as
many other ones again in samples can
ativ the repository in a sample repo
alright so there's a couple of nice
things that you get out of using event
sources right so if you have used get up
or Twitter or any of any of these other
systems that already produce or are
capable of emitting events you can go
and go out today and go to some webpage
or tools and create these for yourself
and point them at something else as well
but it's not it's the event sources the
benefits of using them in this way is
that it actually means that they are
declared it right
so you can go ahead and create this in
your cluster you can actually see them
so as Mark was showing there you can say
what are the subscriptions that I have
going on for me right now you don't have
to go ahead and remember how things are
done
in a sense that you know creating web
hooks and various websites
it's almost different and in it's
different difficult to remember how they
were created and there's all these
how-to pages and so forth so by using
the eventing sources you can do this all
declaratively you can check into
convicts into your source control which
I'm sure you are all doing because
convict is code so you you are taking
doing all the right things and they also
reconcilable so if you make changes
those event sources then all the right
things happen for you underneath so the
source is then responsible for taking
care of that on the on the authoritative
side so that's that's really really nice
and the last bit is that there is now a
very clear separation of concerns so
that the broker is basically creating a
nice little eventing mesh that takes in
all the events and then the user focuses
on routing those events to the
appropriate functions by using triggers
so that's nice and then on the other
side we have these event sources that
are responsible for them establishing
the control plane and the data plane and
ensuring that those events are now
delivered in the broker so there's a
nice little clean separation there so
while the Kay Native community has
provided many of these event sources
already as I mentioned earlier there's
probably some some some that we haven't
done yet I know there's a lot of them
for younger and and and you might also
have some internal systems right that do
you want to go ahead and say it would be
really nice if that thing that I already
have would produce events for me and we
think that saying great just rewrite it
so that it's cloud native is probably
not the best answer so we can go ahead
and make sure that we can take these
bits of code within the form of event
sources and kind of bridge those two
worlds together so let's look at a
little bit at this and see what is sort
of kind of involved in building one of
these event sources so so there's really
two concerns that you have to think
about so one of them is the control
plane so the control plane is the one
where where you are asking some external
system external the brokers might say
external I don't really care whether its
internal or external but I do think
it's outside of the brokers realm so
it's external to broker so there's a
control plane action where you are
asking some system to go ahead and start
sending you events that are filtered
according to your specification so here
are some examples create a get creating
a github webhook for a particular
repository and defining what kinds of
event types you might care about so PRS
commits comments and things like that or
creating a GCP pub/sub subscription or
GCS object storage mode notification and
so forth I'm sure you can all hopefully
think of a couple of other systems that
that are not on that list and then there
is also the concern about the data plane
right so it's great that you have asked
somebody to send your events but where
are they going to be sent to right so
that is the concern of the data plane so
in this case for example we can go ahead
and create a data plane component that
receives two github webhook events or we
can go ahead and have a have a piece of
software that is running on our cluster
that is responsible for handling pull
models because there's both kinds of
models out there right so there's push
and pull based ones so so on the control
plane at the kinds of so while on the
broker side of things we are
standardizing on the cloud events and
there's a nice little a control plane
component there that allows you to you
that there is nothing like that
unfortunately out there that allows us
to go and have a standard way of
subscribing the events everywhere and
and I don't think that that's gonna
happen anytime soon but it may be nice
but if you look at for example marks
when Mark was demonstrating the Twitter
example right there was things that he
had to go and specify like I don't know
credentials right so credentials come in
different kinds of formats so the
control plane has to be customized for a
particular event source so that it knows
how to authenticate itself and so forth
they also all have different custom API
so the nice thing is that many of these
there's many many libraries that you can
go and pull in the in in the form of
your own choosing language will be a
choice and then it also has to reconcile
so I basically I mentioned earlier that
if I make changes to the Twitter example
and
and reapply those changes then the
Twitter source is going to be
responsible for pushing those and
modifying the control plane bits as
necessary and and the second bit that
the control plane needs to do is asset
is setting up the control plane it
obviously needs to go and point it at
something and establish the data plane
soakin so the so the event source is
also responsible for setting up the data
plane components and a couple of reasons
for that
or well there's probably some
authentication that has to happen at the
data plane also right so if you for
example set up a github webhook then one
of the things one of the ways that you
can authenticate there is by using a
shared secret so the source is going to
go and set up a brand Oh secret give it
to github because nobody else cares
about it gives it the github and gives
it the data plane and and and you're off
the races and then obviously control
play needs to go and clean up after it's
done so once you decide that maybe you
don't want this anymore
it's responsible now for going in and
deleting the deleting the external
sources so that you don't have to
remember say like oh I don't want to
receive those events now here's a piece
of documentation that tells you how to
undo all the stuff that you did before
so really this is just a simple picture
where the event source on the left hand
the yellow ones those are the custom
pieces of goat code that run on your
cluster so there's two of them there
there's a github and a GCSE and both of
them are talking to a control plane one
of them the github API using the green
one and one of them due to cloud storage
and they're just establishing that data
plane on the right hand side there to
the broker that's what they are
conceptually saying please go and send
those events
send them over the broker over there
well that's nice but then this is where
you have to worry about things like the
data plane right so while everything
within K native eventing is cloud events
so the broker says I only take cloud
events right I mean I separation of
concerns so the data plane is going to
have to normalize those events that are
coming in from the external sources
convert them into cloud events and hand
them off over to the broker they also
need to as I mentioned deal with with
an occasion and authorization so just
because somebody sends you an event from
the outside world you want to make sure
that it actually is the one that you
subscribe to so that's where the
coordination between the control plane
of the event source and the and the data
plane there's some coordination that
needs to happen and again there's pol
versus push so some examples are for GCP
pops up you can run in both modes you
can run an importer of push mode so
depending on how you want to go ahead
and set up your data plane you have
choices there push base obviously lends
itself very nicely the que native
serving so that many of these event
sources that are push based are
implemented using just a que native
service yes yes and so so it roughly
looks like this so that we are kind of
covered everything about the pro core
anyway on so these the first part was
the control plan the yellows now here's
sort of kind of the data playing for you
so you can see that the for example the
FTP receive adapter that that we have
written for example is the one that it
is pool based because many of the FTP
servers out there don't expose a a push
based model or they don't expose any
notification so you you have to go ahead
and do something like this but this is a
good example of being able to take a
little bit of glue code and saying you
know now all of a sudden without
changing anything on the original source
that you cared about you can go and
write a little bit of Shin code and go
and print those eventing capabilities
now to an existing system out there and
then github in GCS so they all sending
different kinds of events they off they
go into their respective receive
adapters and out comes nice normalized
cloud events that then can handoff the
broker obviously they contain different
kinds of payloads so if you look at the
one on the bottom there there's a
there's a quick example of sort of kind
of what these magical cloud events look
like so there's this kind of a standard
envelope around it and then the pale
goes in the data there so it's very easy
for the for the function writers to go
and reason about please all right so
there's basically three standard-based
today to go and by demand sources so one
of them is the hey I want to go ahead
and do it all myself
I'm gonna write a kubernetes controller
because that is fun and that's a lot of
work so we came up with something called
K native container source I'll talk a
little bit about that one and then the
last bit is where you already have some
running code that you have control over
and you want to go and just start
emitting events from there so the K
native the the kubernetes operator is
basically a this is a standard way that
you basically add a new object type in
the kubernetes you basically define a
CRD that says this is what the objects
look like and then you've got a
controller that sits there and looks at
those objects and we consult the world
and then you have webhook that is that
is that is authenticating and default
validating and defaulting and things
like that so it's only three pieces but
it's a lot of work trust me
I've written a few of these so that's a
lot of work and it's very complicated to
get it right and so forth there's a
great example that actually uses this
which is the GCP pub/sub controller so
I'm not gonna go through the code but
there it is you can go look at it so
what we did at the K native or like okay
look it's really really hard so let's go
ahead and write one controller that is
easy for you to reason about because you
just say hey when a new event type gets
created like the Twitter so good example
this is the Twitter one so when we
showed you the Twitter one this is this
is the Twitter source is using the
container soulish so you basically just
say like blood I don't know where I
can't rate I don't want to write a
kubernetes controller I'm just going to
give you a container can you run this
for me when you go ahead and establish a
new subscription modified and delete it
so that's that's what the that's what
you can do with the container source you
just give us a controller controller
container and env run it for you and the
nice thing is its language neutral so
you can whatever code you have just wrap
it up in a container and bring it to us
and with this model you can also go
ahead and
it's possible to come back combine the
control and data plane and one example
of this is the kubernetes event source
so so this is this is the kubernetes
event source that take runs on your
cluster it looked what she's for
kubernetes events and turns them into
que native events for you so then you
can go and do things like automate some
some aspects of your kubernetes cluster
yourself and things like that and
there's obviously more code here but
really it really they and there's a link
to it but the only things that it really
cares about it sets up the control plane
um there it basically uses kubernetes
client and says hey I want to go ahead
and start watching for event types or
poobah natus events and when those
events happen please call this little
function for me and all that and that's
the add event function there and the
only thing that that function has to do
is take that wrap it up in a cloud event
and ship it off the broker and and you
are done so that is that is a pretty
simple one to do and then let's say you
already have some code running and this
is this is our super secure login
service here for example where the only
thing we want to do is we have some
running code and B has some places where
we would like to go ahead and extend
that system by meeting some events so
all we have to do is is is from that
existing code decide where we want to
send the events sorry when we want to
omit events and instantiate a new cloud
events client so in this case it's our
own internal events I just wrap it up in
a cloud events and my day dies then
whatever you want it to be right so
those are kind of the three three ways
of doing it in the in the order of
decreasing difficulty if you will and
there's a cloud events SDK there's one
one good example the the cloud events
repo as I mentioned the spec there is
say that's a go Lang because this is
glow line but you can use that so it's
pretty easy for you to go ahead and and
do this yourself if you want to
all right we've barely made it on time
but hopefully you give you a good
overview of the K native events and the
capabilities they're in it's very hard
to kind of go super deep but also fit it
all in an hour and level set there's a
lot of examples that are available on a
K native website if you go to our cave
without dev and drill down into samples
you will see all different simple events
all the way to very complex ones and you
can kind of pace yourself we also have
walked through some the spectrum of the
way you can interact with events you can
start with very simplistic one we might
not be able to reconcile your sources
and migrate over time to something more
complex again a lot of those event
sources have already been written so you
don't have to be in that business if
unless you don't want to unless you want
to so hopefully this was good in for
informative session there's a couple
links in here where you can get hold of
us as well as you ask some deeper
questions on a candidate of slack it's
just access key native that's logged
comm that will redirect you to slack
directly and you can ask channel the
different channels for eventing
community simple the general one which
always good place to start with and
obviously we have this week we have kind
of announced cloud run tyronn doesn't
support cloud events yet
for this kind of service but as you can
imagine we we're looking forward to the
time where we can offer that service -
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]